the idea that we can do this project of
nation building that like by analogy
with what we did with post World War II
with Germany and Japan which are are
miracles of Resurrection really I mean
look at look at the enemies we had in
Germany and Japan and look at the state
of the world now the idea that they are
our friends and collaborators and have
been for virtually for as long as you
know we've been alive it's it's an
amazing reboot of civilization after its
near destruction um the idea that we can
accomplish that in the Middle East and
accomplish that in a Muslim culture just
because we think everyone must want
freedom on some level and must want to
run the same Democratic code as we do
and you know dye their fingers and say
they voted I'm much more pessimistic
about that project ever being fulfill in
the lifetime of anyone hearing this than
I
was